Britney Spears Jennifer Lopez here's  what your favorite stars r up to over  the weekend cool very cool  Britney posted this throwback shot of  herself late Sunday night writing quote  my friend sent me this picture today and  it's weird because I just realized it's  one of the only pictures I've ever taken  upside down it's a lot of fun  JLo was out in Miami 47 year-olds  reposted this candid video of herself  shaking it  I really feel blessed Lisa Rinna put  herself on display to check out this  bikini photo she posted go for it baby  Real Housewives star added HH brought me  back a lips bikini yes my hair is  different in this shots and yes I'm 53  and yes I can own it and 90 year old  Hugh Hefner broke his Twitter silence on  Thursday after not posting since  September playboy founder retweeted this  pic that his son shared on Thanksgiving  quote hope everyone is having a lovely  evening with family and friends happy  Thanksgiving all